so we make the individual labor mayor the
master of his union and in the entire can
elect a proper officer to run his union that's
what we want to do no longer after my bill is
enacted well a few people go into a labor hall
and hold up their hand and say I vote for this
person under my bill he has a right to vote in
secret ballot as to who's gonna head his union
also there's a provision in my ability as an
individual has a right to vote whether he wants
to strike her god this is what America needs
this is the answer to our problem in America
I'm glad you asked me that I presume that you were
referring to mr. Hoffa and others I can tell you
right now that in due time the provisions of my
bill will give men like that a haircut and they'll
have to be good boys Kennedy well I'll tell
you it's so strong yet it's appealing in other
words we are not hurting management we're not
hurting labor we're trying to do a job here that
reflects the responsibility the labor movement and
management's do to the public to the United States